my name is Miata David Johnson I'm
founder and CEO of MTD a hi my name is
masa David I am co-founder of MBD Inc
NBC Inc is a creative agency we've done
a lot of pre awards dinners or awards
events album release events one of the
experiences most recently that people
are familiar with us from is the Wyoming
listing event that we did for Kanye West
I'm a Liberian immigrant and my father
was the mayor of Monrovia so we actually
left Liberia after the coup our parents
really it was what they instilled in us
at you know when we moved to the states
and just in general that I think really
helped to determine our work ethic and
the kind of company that we would
eventually form I watched my father kind
of build his self from the ground up he
went from being the mayor to basically
selling shoes just to support the family
and he eventually opened his own
business and I saw early on what it
means to be an entrepreneur and you
really stand out in this industry
because it is male-dominated you don't
find a lot of female event producers and
just a lot of females in positions of
power in our business so it's been
always extremely challenging because
you're constantly showing and proving
why you belong in the room I think for
two women not just two women but also
siblings and african-american women we
make it a point to hire other women it's
rare to see that especially in this
industry in just in Hollywood in general
one of definitely our funniest craziest
moments I would say in events is we did
an event in New York not too long ago he
was brand new but people were excited
about him we did it at an art gallery
and basically the whole vibe of the
album was anarchy so you know the artist
wanted to have a vibe that would be fun
and easy and his friends can really just
have a good time but we maybe I would
say maybe a six hours prior to doors
opening we found out that somebody
actually posted the invite on Twitter
and Instagram to their millions of
followers so we basically had all of New
York outside and we start texting the
label and everyone and turns out one of
his friends
the invite and next thing you know our
door was just bombarded we had to
basically scramble make sure that we got
more security let the city know so that
we wouldn't get shut down
it was definitely me and my sister was
actually on the ground in New York and I
was in LA so I was doing this remotely
it got to the point where I had to get
behind the bar and start serving drinks
like it was that crazy even started it
was absolutely insane it was chaotic it
was like an old-school Lower East Side
party you know got everyone in
everyone's having an amazing time people
are drinking they're vibing and the next
thing you know the music turns off and
I'm running over to the DJ booth like
why are you turning the music off what's
going on at this point he's definitely
tipsy he's he's gone he's on cloud nine
but he's pissed because he thinks
someone stole his cell phone
I remember reliving it on social media
cuz I wasn't there so I'm just looking
at the ceiling watching how he lost his
phone at the venue and made everybody
turn the music off he gets on the mic
and he starts cursing I know one of you
did it and no more party everyone
believe everyone's laughing and ignoring
him and just pulling out their phones to
report it he tells someone next to him
like call my phone so they call his cell
phone and literally there was probably
about 500 people there and we all got
quiet so he was like listening out for
the phone he calls it we hear it and he
calls it again at this point everyone in
the party is searching trying to find
his phone turns out he forgot that he
left it at the DJ booth under the DJ's
backpack so he finds it he put me throws
it in the air everyone loses their mind
screaming the music comes back on I mean
it was just it was insane it was
probably one of my favorite events the
artist he still talks about it he
actually put it in one of his songs what
I learned is watch over my client social
media because you sometimes may get
surprised as to seeing your event posted
on their social media before their
learning starts I think that event
really taught me that regardless of how
much you prepare and plan and think
ahead you just have to be ready and
prepared for the unexpected
hi I think that working with siblings
and working with family gets a bad rap
when you figure out your rhythm you have
a trusted partner for life follow your
own path and regardless of any industry
that you go into don't try to change and
conform to what people want you to be
but celebrate what makes you different
[Music]